MEMBER GIVES NOT THE OF A- THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THE CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA
BARRICADE HAND BENT BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN CHIU CHOI
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY
DALY DAVIES FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA.
KILEY BLACKY LEE LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN SUU KYI
AS AREA WIND O'DONNELL
PATTERSON PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK
CORK SILVA. RAMOS RADIUS LOOSE
THREE ROBERT TO REVIEW
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS SANTIAGO
SAY ARTURO SMITH STONE TEEN
CALAVERAS BE APPROVED BY A- L.
WALDRON. WARD WEBER WICKS WORD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. ON A QUORUM
IS PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER. AND IN
THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. THE DAYS PRAYER
WILL BE OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS THIS
PENSIONERS. LORD THIS PAST YEAR
AND A HALF HAS BEEN A ROLLER
COASTER THAT HAS AT TIMES FELT
REALLY THE POLITICAL. WE HAVE
BEEN IN THE VALLEY AND WE HAVE
BEEN ON THE MOUNTAIN TOP. WE
HAVE SWUNG FROM HOPE TO DESPAIR
AND BACK AGAIN. ALONG THE WAY
WE HAVE LEARNED JUST HOW LITTLE
CONTROL WE SOMETIMES HAVE AS WE
NAVIGATE THE MYSTERY OF LIFE.
FOR MANY OF US THAT LESSON HAS
BEEN JARRING. BUTIT HAS ALSO
BEEN AN OPPORTUNITY. TO KNOCK
THE NOISE AND FOCUS ON WHAT IS
IMPORTANT TO FIND THE BEAUTY
AND SMALL THINGS TO RECOGNIZE
OUR SHARED HUMANITY. AND ELEVEN
OUR NEIGHBORS AS OURSELVES. WE
COME TOGETHER TODAY AND A
SPIRIT OF PROFOUND HUMILITY
HOPE AND GRATITUDE. I LAST
OFFERED A PRAYER BEFORE THIS
BODY SOME NINE MONTHS AGO IS
OUR TWENTY TWENTY LEGISLATIVE
SESSION WAS DRAWING TO A CLOSE
WE WERE REALLY AND TRULY AND A
MOMENT. OF UNIMAGINABLE CRISIS
THE PANDEMIC WAS REACHING THE
ECONOMY WAS IN FREE FALL OUR
CONSTITUENTS WERE DESPERATE.
STANDING HERE TODAY I LOOK BACK
WITH MUCH WONDER I JUST FAR WE
HAVE COME. THE MIRACLE OF THE
COULD NINETEEN VACCINE HAS
BECOME A REALITY OUR SCHOOLS
ARE RE OPENING OUR BUSINESSES
ARE WELCOMING BACK CUSTOMERS
AND OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE
RETURNING TO WORK. WE ARE NOW
PLEASED TO PUT THE NIGHTMARE AT
THIS PANDEMIC BEHIND US AND
BUILD BACK OUR GREAT STATE.
INDEED THERE IS MUCH TO BE
GRATEFUL FOR AND ONCE AGAIN
THIS BODY IS AT A CRITICAL
JUNCTURE. WE ARE TASKED WITH
FORGING A SWIFT EQUITABLE AND
ROBUST RECOVERY FOR CALIFORNIA.
AND WE ARE BLESSED WITH
UNPRECEDENTED RESOURCES TO MEET
THIS CHALLENGE AND TO SERVE THE
PEOPLE OF THIS GREAT STATE. AS
WE APPROACH THIS NEXT SEASON.
MAY YOU GRANT US WISDOM MAY YOU
HELP US DISTINGUISH THE WHEAT
FROM THE CHAFF AND MAY YOU HELP
US BUILD OUR HOUSE ON A STRONG
FOUNDATION SO THAT WE MAY BUILD
BACK CALIFORNIA STRONGER THAN
BEFORE. ON. DAVIS PETRIE-NORRIS
YES OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE. PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIGELOW AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
BIGELOW. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SALUTING OUR FLAG I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. THANK
YOU MAY BE SEATED. READING OF
THE PREVIOUS JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
TERMS TO USE ABLE TO TWO TWENTY
ONE THE ASSEMBLY MINUTES OF AM
THE MIKE GIPSON MEMBER SIXTY
FOUR DISTURBANCE OUT INTO
CHEAPER DE READY FOR DAVID WHEN
READING ROLL CALL THE FOLLOWING
REPLACED ONE MORNING OR IS
REYES MOVE. AND VALID THEIR
SECOND. AT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S BE TO WITH.
PRESIDENT TO PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE. REFERENCE OF WILL BE.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
READ AMENDMENTS IT. MESS FROM
THE GOVERNOR. THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES THE SENATE. THERE ARE
NONE. MOTIONS AND- THE ABSENCES
FOR THE DAY FOR ILLNESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON FOR
ILLNESS IN THE FAMILY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHEN.
THERE IS WHERE I
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. MS RACE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER- PLEASE REMOVE
THE ITEM ONE AWAIT AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR GRAYSON FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AT THE REQUEST
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH. THE CLERK WILL
NOTE. MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE
SECOND READING. COVERAGE. SOME
PEOPLE FOR NINETY ONE FIVE OH
TO PEOPLE SEVEN THOSE. ALL BILL
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND DEEMED
ADOPTED. MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
TO THE FILE. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO START BY TAKING UP
FILE ITEM EIGHTY FIVE. THIS IS
MISTER RODRIGUEZ'S RESOLUTION
THIS IS. FILE ITEM. EIGHTY
FIVE. ACR. SEVENTY SIX THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SEVENTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ RELATIVE TO EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES WEEK MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE ATTENTION AS
RODRIGUEZ MISS RODRIGUEZ YOU
MAY OPEN. MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO
OVER EIGHTY THOUSAND EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICE PERSONNEL WHO
TREAT OVER TWO MILLION
CALIFORNIANS A YEAR. ACR
SEVENTY SIX HONORED THESE
PROFESSIONALS A PROCLAIM MAY
SIXTEENTH THROUGH MAY TWENTY
SECOND AS EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES WEEK IN CALIFORNIA.
EMS WEEK IS OUR ANNUAL CAMPAIGN
DEDICATED TO RECOGNIZING THE
VALUE AND DEDICATION OF THESE
PROFESSIONALS WHO PROVIDE
LIFESAVING CARE TO OTHERS IN
THE TIME AND NEED. EMS
PERSONNEL HAVE MADE SIGNIFICANT
SACRIFICES IN THE COURSE OF
THEIR DUTIES WHICH INCLUDES
PLACE IN THEIR OWN LIVES ON THE
LINE. AS WELL AS MISSING
SPECIAL MOMENTS WITH THE
FAMILIES AND FRIENDS. AS MANY
OF YOU KNOW OF THE EMPTY FOR
OVER THIRTY YEARS I CAN ATTEST
TO THE TRUE PROFESSIONALISM.
PASSION THESE INDIVIDUALS BRING
TO THEIR WORK. DUE TO THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC OR EMS
PERSONNEL. HAD TO FACE AN EVEN
BIGGER CHALLENGE. BUT THE
RESPONSE WAS TREMENDOUS. THEIR
SENSE OF DUTY AND DEDICATION TO
OUR COMMUNITIES IMPROVE
SURVIVAL AND RECOVERY RATES TO
THOSE WHO EXPERIENCED ILLNESSES.
MANY LARGE WERE LOSS BUT THEIR
SERVICE AND BRAVERY WILL NEVER
BE FORGOTTEN. THIS RESOLUTION
CONDEMNED COMMANDS ALL OF
CALIFORNIA EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICE PROVIDERS FOR THEIR
SACRIFICE AND DEDICATION ON
YOUR DESK YOU'RE FINDING EMS
THE POP IN. MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN
ME IN WEARING THIS WARRANT AT
THIS WEEK TO HONOR OUR EMS
PERSONNEL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
HER AYE VOTE AND WOULD LIKE TO
REQUEST THAT THE FIRST WILL BE
OPEN FOR A CO AUTHORS. THANK
YOU MYSTERY. SEEING NO OR
DEBATE ON THIS RESOLUTION.
MEMBERS THE AUTHOR IS ASKING
THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON THE RESOLUTION THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS ON ACR SEVENTY SIX.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. CO
AUTHORS.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER
AUTHOR SIXTY ONE CO AUTHORS
ADDED IN WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED.
DEVER'S BACK AT THE
TOP OF THE FILE FILE ITEMS FOUR
AND FIVE PASS AND RETAIN PASS
TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM SIX
FILE ITEMS SEVEN. THROUGH
SIXTEEN PASS AND RETAIN WEIRD
FILE ITEM. SEVENTEEN THIS IS AB
FIVE THIRTY FIVE I MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY THE CLERK WILL
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE THIRTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WE ARE
CURRY AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE IN
THE FOOD LABELING. MS
AGUIAR-CURRY THANK YOU MR
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AB FIVE
THIRTY FIVE CLARIFIES EXISTING
LAW THE PROHIBITS THE LABELING
OF ALL OF WELL AS FROM
CALIFORNIA. LIVE A 100% OF THE
OIL IS FROM OLIVES GROWN IN THE
STATE. MEMBERS THIS BILL IS NOT
ABOUT ONE COMPANY IT'S ABOUT AN
ENTIRE INDUSTRY MADE UP OF MORE
THAN FOUR HUNDRED FARMERS.
FORTY FIVE MILLS. THOUSANDS OF
EMPLOYEES THAT HAVE BEEN
WORKING TO MAKE CALIFORNIA ALL
OF WORLD THE FINEST IN THE
WORLD. IT'S A GROWING INDUSTRY
AS PHARMACY CROPPING CHANGES.
AS A RESULT OF CLIMATE CHANGE
AND LESS ACCESS TO WATER ALL OF
US ARE GROWING IN POPULARITY.
WITH THAT IS BUT THAT IS ALSO
THE GROWTH IN ALL OF OIL FROM
CALIFORNIA. THE TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN LAW CENTER LOS WALK
CARILLO. TO CREATE THE
CALIFORNIA OLIVE OIL
COMMISSION. THE COMMISSION WAS
CREATED WITH UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
FROM THE INDUSTRY. OUR FOCUS OF
THAT INDUSTRY AT THE TIME WAS
TO DISTINGUISH THE PURITY OF
CALIFORNIA ALL OF OIL FROM
IMPORTS ALLEGED TO CONTAIN
COUNTERFEIT INGREDIENTS. AND
THEREBY PENETRATE THE US MARKET
WHICH AT THE TIME CONSISTENT
MOST ENTIRELY OF IMPORTS.
CALIFORNIA IMPURITY FOR THE
MARK HE WORDS USED WHEN THE
COMMISSION WAS FORMED AND THE
QUALITY STANDARDS LATER
DEVELOPED. AB FIVE THIRTY FIVE
BUILT UPON THE HISTORY BY
CLOSING A LOOPHOLE IN EXISTING
LAW. SINCE NINETEEN FORTY THREE
CALIFORNIA LAW HAS REGULATED
THE LABELING OF ALL OF WORLD IN
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN THE LAW
WAS CHANGED TO PROTECT THE USE
OF THE TERM CALIFORNIA. AB FIVE
THIRTY FIVE DOES NOT CHANGE THE
RULES EXISTING LAW SEEKS TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS FROM
INHERENTLY DECEPTIVE LABELS.
AND AB FIVE THIRTY FIVE EXTENDS
UP PROTECTION. I'VE HEARD FROM
HUNDREDS OF SMALL GROWERS ALL
OF OIL PRODUCERS AND AG
ORGANIZATIONS ASKING US TO
PROTECT THE CALIFORNIA BRAND
FOR ALL THESE REASONS. WHY
ESTABLISHING STRONGER LABELING
GUIDELINES FOR ALL OF OUR
PRODUCERS AB FIVE THIRTY FIVE
WILL ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA
BRAND IS PROTECTED AND
CONSUMERS KNOW WHEN A LABEL
SAYS CALIFORNIA AND THE ORAL IS
A 100% CALIFORNIA. A LOT OF MY
COLLEAGUES FROM RURAL
CALIFORNIA MAKE A GREAT POINT
OF BRAGGING ABOUT CALIFORNIA
ACCURATE NUMBER CULTURE. AS TO
WHY NOW IS THEIR CHANCE TO
SUPPORT THE FARMERS THEY CLAIM
TO REPRESENT. A LOT OF YOU HAVE
PROBABLY VOTED TO INCREASE
STANDARDS AND WAGES FOR THE
INDUSTRY NOW IS THE TIME TO
PROVE YOU'LL ALSO PROTECT THESE
FARMERS AGAINST COUNTRIES WHO
DON'T MEET OUR STANDARDS. I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU IS
A YEAR MISTER GALLAGHER YOUR
RECOGNIZE. THEY YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MA'AM- I GREATLY
RESPECT MY COLLEAGUE. FROM
WINNERS WHO WE WORKED ON MANY
ISSUES TOGETHER- MANY RURAL
ISSUES TOGETHER WATER ISSUES
AGRICULTURAL ISSUES BUT I MUST
RESPECTFULLY AND PASSIONATELY
DISAGREE WITH THIS MEASURE IN
THIS BILL. AND I PLEAD WITH MY
COLLEAGUES ON THIS FLOOR TODAY.
THIS WILL BE THE FIRST TIME IN
HISTORY. THAT WE PASS A BILL
THAT IS TARGETED TOWARDS
EXACTLY ONE BUSINESS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. TARGETING
THEM AND PUTTING THEM AT A
GROSS DISADVANTAGE. AND I WANT
YOU TO ASK YOURSELF IF THIS
HAPPENED TO YOU IN YOUR
DISTRICT AND ONE OF YOUR
BUSINESSES WAS SPECIFICALLY
TARGETED BY A BILL WHAT WOULD
YOU WANT. DONE LET ME BACK UP A
LITTLE BIT AND TALK ABOUT THIS
BUSINESS CALIFORNIA OLIVE RANCH
HASBEEN IN BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS. EMPLOYS CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS. CONTRACTS WITH
CALIFORNIA ALL OF GROWERS. IN
THE STATE TO TALK ABOUT HOW
THESE PEOPLE SOMEHOW ARE NOT A
CALIFORNIA BASED BUSINESS IS
COMPLETELY RIDICULOUS. NO THEY
DON'T SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA
ALL OF INDUSTRY IS ALSO
RIDICULOUS. THEY'VE HAD THIS
NAME FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS AND
TODAY WERE SAYING THEY CAN'T
HAVE THAT NAME IF YOU PASS THIS
BILL. YOU'RE SAYING AND THEIR
BRAND NAME THEY CAN'T USE THE
WORD CALIFORNIA ALL OF RANCH.
ON THEIR LABELS THEY SELL A
100% CALIFORNIA OLIVE OIL. IN
THEIR BRANDS AND THEY ALSO SELL
A BLENDED OLIVE OIL JUST LIKE
EVERYBODY ELSE IN THE INDUSTRY
DOES THIS PEOPLE WITH 1100%
CALIFORNIA GROWN THEY ALSO
BLENDED VERSIONS THEY DO THE
SAME THING BUT THEY HAPPEN TO
HAVE THE NAME FOR TWENTY PLUS
YEARS A TRADEMARKED. YOU HAVE
GOT IT FROM THE CALIFORNIA
SECRETARY OF STATE WHEN THEY
FORM THE CORPORATION. OVER
TWENTY YEARS AGO OF HAD THAT
NAME FOREVER BUT BUT THIS
LEGISLATURE TODAY IF YOU PASS
THIS BILL YOU'RE GOING TO SAY
THEY CAN'T HAVE THAT NAME
ANYMORE. THEY CAN'T USE IT. ON
THEIR BRANDS THAT THEY'VE BEEN
SELLING IN CALIFORNIA AGAIN
USING CALIFORNIA GROWERS THAT
THEY CONTRACT WITH USING
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYEES OVER A
HUNDRED FORTY IN CALIFORNIA
WORKING FOR THIS COMPANY. IS
THAT THE KIND OF PERSON THAT
WE'RE GOING TO SAID I HOPE I
REALLY HOPE NOT. AND I'M
BEGGING YOU MEMBERS DON'T PASS
THIS BILL. JUST BECAUSE- THINK
ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE DOING HERE
WE'VE ASKED FOR REASONABLE
AMENDMENTS. TO THIS BILL TO
ENSURE THAT IT DOESN'T INFRINGE
ON THE TRADEMARK NAME ON A
TRADEMARK BRAND NAME FOR A
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS MAKE THE
AMENDMENT. TAKE THE REASONABLE
AMENDMENTS. BUT DON'T MOVE THIS
FORWARD TODAY MEMBERS ASK YOU
TO VOTE NO THANK YOU. MS RUBIO
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE THIRTY FIVE
AN ISSUE CONTINUOUSLY
CHAMPIONED BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM
WINTERS. SINCE I WAS ELECTED I
HAVE MADE IT A PRIORITY TO
RECOGNIZE AN ADVOCATE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE
AGRICULTURAL FOOTPRINT. THREE
VARIETY OF MEETINGS AND TOURS I
HAVE DEVELOPED A PROFOUND
UNDERSTANDING OF ONE OF
CALIFORNIA'S MOST RENOWNED
INDUSTRIES ARE FARMERS
RIGHTFULLY TAKE PRIDE IN
GROWING CALIFORNIAPRODUCTS
RECOGNIZED WORLDWIDE. THIS BILL
IS SIMPLY LOOKING TO PROTECT
THE REPUTATION AND NAME THEY
HAVE CREATED OVER THE YEARS TO
ENSURE THE CONSUMER IS GETTING
CALIFORNIA PRODUCTS WHEN THEY
SEE CALIFORNIA ON THE LABEL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
THANK YOU MISTER VOC NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION. ON
THE BILL MISS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU. MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE THOUGHTFUL
DEBATE I'VE LEFT SOME QUESTIONS
FOR MY CLOTHES AND I THINK
EVERYONE OF US AGREES THE
CALIFORNIA FARMERS WORK WITH
THE MOST PROTECTIVE CONSUMER
ENVIRONMENTAL LABOR STANDARDS.
IN THE WORLD. THIS BILL IS
MEANT TO SUPPORT THEM WHEN
PLAYERS IN THE FALL OF MARKETS
ATTEMPT TO BYPASS THOSE
STANDARDS IS ALL BOILS FROM
OTHER PLACES. AND PRESENT
THEMSELVES OF CALIFORNIANS.
CURRENT LAW SAYS IF ANY ALL OF
OUR PROCESS SOLD OFFERED FOR
SALE GIVEN AWAY OR POSSESSING
CALIFORNIA. THAT INDICATES ON
ITS LABEL CALIFORNIA ALL OF
WORLD OR WORDS OF SIMILAR
IMPACT THAT INDICATE THE
CALIFORNIA IS THE SOURCE OF THE
OIL A 100% OF THAT OIL SHALL BE
DERIVED FROM OLIVES GROWN IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS LANGUAGE WAS
UNIVERSALLY SUPPORTED WHEN IT
BECAME LAW INCLUDING THE MOST
VOCAL OPPONENT OF THIS BILL.
THEY CHANGED OWNERS. AND
DECIDED NOT TO OFFER THE SAME
PRODUCT ANYMORE THAT'S THEIR
DECISION AND IT'S THEIR RIGHT
TO DO THAT. BUT IF YOU'RE NO
LONGER MEET THE STANDARDS IN
THE LAW YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
USE THE WORDS OF SIMILAR IMPORT
THAT INDICATE THE CALIFORNIA
BOARD REGION WITH IN CALIFORNIA
IS THE SOURCE OF THE OIL. I'VE
BEEN ASKED ABOUT WORKING WITH
OPPONENTS THE POTENTIAL
AMENDMENTS. OVER THE PAST TWO
YEARS INCLUDING THE LAST FEW
WEEKS AFTER HEALTH COMMUNITY
WE'VE ENGAGE WITH THE OPPONENTS
AND HAVE EVERY INTENTION TO DO
SO FURTHER. TO DATE HOWEVER THE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS WOULD DO
NOTHING BUT REMOVE THE
CLARIFICATION WHICH IS THE
WHOLE POINT OF THE BILL AND
EXEMPT INDIVIDUALS. I CANNOT DO
EITHER. BUT I ASSURE MY
QUALITIES I'M PAUL THESE I'M
NOT DONE TRYING TO FIND A PATH.
I'VE BEEN ASKED ABOUT
LITIGATION DUE TO FEDERAL LEGAL
ISSUES THE FEDERAL COURTS HAVE
RULED THAT MISLEADING
COMMERCIAL SPEECH IS NOT
PROTECTED BY THE CONSTITUTION.
OUR OWN ATTORNEYS IN THE
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL HAVE NOT
FLAG THIS BILL FOR A RISK OF
CONFLICT WITH FEDERAL LAW WHEN
I INTRODUCED THE SAME BILL LAST
YEAR NOR AGAIN THIS YEAR. WE
ARE WAITING FOR AN OPINION TO
LAY THIS TO REST BUT
UNFORTUNATELY IT WILL NOT BE
AVAILABLE UNTIL LATER THIS
SUMMER. I ALSO WANT TO ADDRESS
THE MIS CHARACTERIZATIONS OF MY
MOTIVES BY MY OPPONENTS AND
EVEN MY COLLEAGUES. I TAKE
GREAT EXCEPTION TO THE
SUGGESTION BY ANYONE THAT THIS
BILL IS INTENDED TO TIP THE
SCALES OF COMPETITION TOWARD OR
AWAY FROM INDIVIDUAL PARTIES. I
WOULD NEVER EVER USE MY OFFICE
NOR THIS FLOOR TO PROMOTE OR
UNDERMINE INDIVIDUAL PARTIES
AND I'M OFFENDED BY THE
SUGGESTION OTHERWISE. MEMBERS
THE LAW IS CLEAR FROM OUT OF
STATE INVESTORS WANT TO IGNORE
THE INTENT OF THE LAW BY
BRANDING BY A BRANDING LOOPHOLE
TO ACCOMPLISH EXACTLY EXACTLY
WHAT WAS PROHIBITED BY THE LAW
USING OUR STATE OR REGIONAL
NAME UNLESS ALL ABOVE A 100%
CALIFORNIA OR 85% PER REGION TO
DO SO IS MISLEADING AND IF THE
COMMENTS ON THE INTERNET FOR
SALE FIVE. MMHM I. ASK THROUGH.
WITHOUT THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE ALL MEMBERS OF. WHAT IS
THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
OUT OF THE- ALL MEMBERS OF THE-
DECIDABLE.
BLACKWELL. CLOSER
ALL TIDE ABOUT I SHOULD BE ONE
KNOWS FIVE THAT MEASURE. PASS A
RETAINER FILE ITEMS EIGHTEEN.
THROUGH TWENTY ONE WE ARE AT
FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO AB
THIRTEEN OH SIX BY DR ARAMBULA
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN OH SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA AND
OTHERS AN ACTOR LIVING HEALTH
PROFESSIONS DOCTOR IN THE LAB.
MR THANK YOU MR SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
AB THIRTEEN OH SIX WHICH AIMS
TO ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S
SHORTAGE OF HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONALS. AB THIRTEEN OH
SIX PROVIDES THE LEGISLATURE
WITH KEY RECOMMENDATIONS
RELATED TO THE HEALTH
PROFESSIONS. CAREERS
OPPORTUNITY PROGRAM. THIS LARGE
SCALE EXPANSION OF
OPPORTUNITIES WILL ADDRESS
BARRIERS THAT LOW INCOME
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS FACE
TO ENTER HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONS
SECURE JOBS AND TO SERVE THEIR
COMMUNITY. AB THIRTEEN OH SIX
ENJOYS STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. MERRY A NO VOTE AND IS
SUPPORTED BY A BROAD COALITION
OF WKFORCE ADVOCATES. THANK
YOU MEMBERS AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
DOCTOR EVER SEEING THEIR
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM. OUR
CLUB THE ROLE. IS IT ALL BETTER
OUT OF A- ALL MEMBERS.
DESIRABLE. CLERK WILL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT I SIXTY SIX
KNOWS THAT MEASURE PASS. PASS
RETAIN ABOUT TWENTY THREE AND
TWENTY FOUR. PASS TEMPORARILY
UNFOLLOW TWENTY. PASS AND
RETAIN ON FILE AB TWENTY SIX
THREE THIRTY. WHERE IT FILE
ITEM THIRTY ONE. THIS IS AB
NINE THIRTY NINE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS CORKERY
WITH AMANDA ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
THIRTY NINE WITH AMENDMENTS BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CERVANTES
MISTER ROGERS ON THE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I
TODAY ARE PRESENT IN A MOMENT
TO ASSEMBLY BILL NINE THREE
NINE THE DENIM ACTIVE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE I WHICH REVEALS A
PROMISE OF DENIM DAY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BY MAKING IT CLEAR
THAT THE SURVIVORS MANNER OF
DRESS CAN NEVER BE USED AS
EVIDENCE OF CONSENT. IN A
SEXUAL ASSAULT CASE THESE
AMENDMENTS ARE TECHNICAL
CHANGES ADD MY COLLEAGUES FROM
ORINDA AS A JOINT AUTHOR AND
ADD MEMBERS FROM THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS AND LGBT CAUCUS AS CO
AUTHORS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I'VE ON THESE AMENDMENTS
AND SEND THE BILL OUT TO PRE
AND BACK ON FILE. THANK YOU
MISTER MONTEZ WITH A- WE MAY
TAKE A- FOR. ON THE AMENDMENTS
THOSE OF SAY AYE. I SAY NAY.
YES I MEMBERS ARE TOP BILLS TO
PRINT. IN BACK ON. FOR FILE
ITEMS THIRTY TWO THROUGH THIRTY
FIVE PASS AND RETAIN THIS IS
FILE ITEM THIRTY SIX AB FIFTEEN
NINETY. THE CORPORATE ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTY NINETY BY THE
COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS AND
OTHERS AND ACCORDING TO THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR. MR
BERMAN YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER COLLEAGUES AB
FIFTEEN NINETY IS ONE OF THE
ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS COMMITTEE'S
ANNUAL OMNIBUS BILLS CONTAINING
MINOR AND NON CONTROVERSIAL
CHANGES TO THE POLITICAL REFORM
ACT. THIS BILL INCLUDES CHANGES
TO STATE LAW THAT WERE
REQUESTED BY THE FAIR POLITICAL
PRACTICES COMMISSION AND OTHER
TECHNICAL CHANGES IDENTIFIED BY
COMMITTEE STAFF SB FIFTY NINETY
SUPPORTED BY THE FAIR POLITICAL
PRACTICES COMMISSION AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
BERMAN SAY NO DISCUSSION. FOR
DEBATE ON THE ADAM. CLIP OF THE
ROCK. IT IS OUR TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF THE DESIRED ABOUT.
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I
FIFTY EIGHT ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEMS THIRTY
THROUGH FORTY THREE PASS AND
RETAIN THIS IS FILE ITEM. FORTY
FOUR EIGHTY SEVEN FORTY SIX BY
MISTER MONTEZ. ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVEN FORTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES INOCULATING TO
ADOPTION THIS MANTAS. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS- AS
LEGISLATURE RECENT YEARS WE
HAVE TAKEN STEPS TO BREAK DOWN
THE BARRIERS OF ALPHA FOR LGBTQ
FAMILIES TO HAVE CHILDREN OR
ADOPT CHILDREN UNFORTUNATELY
OUR CURRENT LAWS DO NOT.
PROHIBIT OUR COURTS FROM ADDING
A MINIMUM MARRIAGE PERIOD
BEFORE COUPLES CAN TAKE A STEP
PARENT ADOPTIONS THE LACK OF
CONSISTENCY HAS LED TO
CONFUSION AND PRACTICE COURTS
IN SOME COUNTIES IMPOSE SUCH A
REQUIREMENT WILL SON DO NOT.
FAMILIES GOING THROUGH THE STEP
PARENT ADOPTION PROCESS ALREADY
ENCOUNTER A CONFUSING AND
COMPLEX SYSTEM WITH THE STATE
AND COUNTY POLICIES THAT WIDELY
VARY FROM COUNTY TO COUNTY. AB
SEVEN FOUR SIX WILL HELP
PROVIDE CLARITY BY PROHIBITING
THE IMPOSITION OF A MINIMUM
MARRIAGE REQUIREMENT FOR
COUPLES SEEKING TO USE A STEP
PARENT ADOPTION PROCESS WE MUST
CONTINUE TO BREAK DOWN BARRIERS
THAT HINDER PRO LONG THE
ADOPTION PROCESS FOR FAMILIES
ESPECIALLY LGBTQ COUPLES. WHO
FACE PERVASIVE OBSTACLES IN THE
PROCESS I RESPECTFULLY. ASK
THREE AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR BY.
SAY NO NEVER SEEKING. CLARK
MORAL. IS THAT A VOTE ON
MEMBERS VETERANS OF OUT. ALL OF
THE- IT IS. WELL. CLOSER ALL
TIED UP BUT I CITY NOW KNOWS
FOR THE MEASURE. PAY RETAIN A
FILE ON FIVE THIS IS FILE ITEM
SIX. A. B. TWENTY NINE BY
MISTER HOLDEN. ARBORETUM
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY HOLDEN AND OTHER AN
APPLE TO PROVIDE IN OKAY. MR
HOLDEN EMAIL THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND- TODAY I'M PRISON
ASSEMBLY BILL TO TUNE THE BILL
THAT PROHIBITS A PERSON REQUIRE
TO BE. A REGISTERED AS A
SECURITY GUARD FROM CARRYING OR
USING A FIRE ARM OR BATON BATON
UNLESS THE SECURITY GUARD IS AN
EMPLOYEE OF A PRIVATE PATROL
OPERATOR LICENSEE. OR AN
EMPLOYEE OF THE STATE. AB TWO
TWO NINE WHAT I. THE APPROACH
USE OF FORCE TO THE TRAINING
COURSES WITHIN THE PRIVATE
SECURITY SERVICES ACT.
INCLUDING TRAINING ON THE USE
OF OBJECTIVELY REASONABLE FORCE
DE ESCALATION TECHNIQUES
IMPLICIT AND EXPLICIT BIAS AND
CULTURAL TRAINING. ADDITIONALLY
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE
COURSE IN THE CURRENT AND USE
OF FIREARMS TO INCLUDE TRAINING
IN THE APPROPRIATE USE OF
FORCE. THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED
BY THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF LICENSE SECURITY AGENCIES
GUARDS AND ASSOCIATES AND HAS
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU MISTER HOLDEN. SEE NOTE OR
DEBATE ON THE OF LOCAL. IT IS
TO VOTE ON THEM OTHERS TO THEM.
ALL MEMBERS WHAT IT IS THAT OF
A. WELL. CLOSE ROLLTIDE I SIXTY
SEVEN. NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. BEVERAGE THIS IS FILE
ITEM FORTY SEVEN. AB THREE
TWENTY THREE BY MISTER KALRA
COOKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
TWENTY THREE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA AN ACT RELATING TO HEALTH
FACILITIES MISTER KALRA. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TWO ONE
THREE TWO THREE REPLACES AN
OUTDATED CAUSATION STANDARD FOR
APPLYING THE CLASS OF THE W.
VIOLATION AND DOBBS OTHER
RECOMMENDATIONS TO INCREASE
PENALTY AMOUNTS FOR NEGLIGENT
CARE TO SAFEGUARD NURSING HOME
AND LONG TERM CARE FACILITY
RESIDENTS. THE PART IN A PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUE A CLASS TO DOUBLE
A AFTER UNDERGOING A THOROUGH
INVESTIGATION OF A SUSPICIOUS
DEATH DETERMINE OF A REGULATION
DESIGNED TO KEEP THE RESIDENT
ALIVE AND SAFE WAS NOT FOLLOWED
DUE TO FACILITY NEGLIGENCE AND
IF THE NEGLIGENCE WAS THE
LEADING CAUSE OF RESULTED IN
THE DEATH OF THAT RESIDENTS.
CURRENTLY THE LAW SAYS IT MUST
BE A DIRECT PROXIMATE CAUSE OF
THE DEATH. WHICH IS A STANDARD
THAT HAS BEEN REJECTED BY THE
COURTS IN APPLYING BECAUSE THAT
IS CONFUSING STANDARD APPLIED
IN FACILITY APPEALS THE
VIOLATION IN SUPERIOR COURT.
USING THE SUBSTANTIAL FACTOR
CAUSATION STANDARD WILL ALLOW
THE DEPARTMENT TO PROPERLY
APPLY THE CLASS DOUBLY
VIOLATION WHEN WARRANTED
THEREBY SAFEGUARDING NURSING
HOME AND OTHER LONG TERM CARE
HEALTH. FACILITY RESIDENTS MY
INTENT IS TO TRY TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH OPPOSITION IN
CONJUNCTION WITH CITY PH ON
ADDRESSING THOSE PLANS
LONGSTANDING ISSUE. HOWEVER
SOME OF THEIR SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS TRY TO PROCEED.
ELEMENT TO SUBSTANTIATE A
CONSTABLE. WAS THE REASON FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S VETO ON A
PREVIOUS BILL. PUT NINETEEN IS
ONLY JUST OF NURSING RESIDENTS
IN HIS REVIEW ONLINE PROBLEMS
EXISTED THE- AB THREE TWO. WILL
US. THE CDC AGES TO. APPLY AND
HOLD ACCOUNT THOSE FOR.
CONGRESS BY. FOR HARM OR DEATH
SO WE CAN BETTER SERVE ROMO
MEDICAL VULNERABLE RESIDENTS.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER KALRA. THIS MR
VOEPEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
MISTER SPEAKER. I RISE NOT TO
THE BILL. IT IS INTENSE GOOD
ALL RIGHT I UNDERSTAND WHERE
YOU'RE COMING FROM MISTER
AUTHOR. BUT THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE WILL BE THIS. IF WE
TIGHTEN UP THE STANDARDS. THEN
WHAT WILL HAPPEN IS THE MEDIC
CAL NURSING HOMES AND LONG TERM
CARE CENTERS. THEY'LL BE
ALLOWED TO SLIDE OUT. THIS WILL
BE A ASSAULT BY ATTORNEYS ON
THE FOR PROFIT. NURSING HOMES
AND LONG TERM CARE CENTERS SOLD
THIS IS SIMPLY A WAY OF POUNDED
THEM DOWN AND IMPACTING THEIR
MONEY NOW THE WAY THE PROFIT.
NURSING HOMES WORK IS THEY
BREAK EVEN ON MEDICARE PATIENTS
THEY MAKE THEIR MONEY ON. THE
SIXTY DAY MEDICARE PATIENTS AND
ALSO THE RICH PEOPLE I MEAN LET
ME PUT IT OUT THERE THE RICH
PEOPLE THAT CAN AFFORD EIGHT
THOUSAND TWELVE THOUSAND A
MONTH. SO WHAT THIS DOES IS IT
WILL ALLOW. LITIGATION THAT
WILL STRIP THE HIGHER IN
NURSING HOMES A BASICALLY THEIR
MONEY AND THEIR ABILITY TO
PROVIDE MEDICARE AL AND A
PROFIT SO THAT'S WHY I'M IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MR VOEPEL.
SHADING NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ADAMA'S CALL OR YOU MAY CLOSE.
JUST RESPONSIBLE OUR COLLEAGUES
THE FEAR. OF WHAT HE'S
DESCRIBED AS TO NOT- PRESENT
THEMSELVES IN FACT IN AND IN
FACT CDPH USES. AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF CARE AT FACILITIES-
OF AN OVER IN FACT EVEN- YOU
KNOW THE LAW ALLOWS YOU TO
PLEASE TO CLOSE HONOR SOCIETY
FOR PETER CLASS OF LICENSE. IT
IS ALSO ONLY A THE LAST YEARS
WAS AFTER. NUMERO REMEDIES RIG
HIMSELF THE INTENTION IS TO
QUALITY CARE AND WORK WITH THIS
ALLOWS YOU TO PH TO HAVE THE
PROP TOOLS ARE UP TO TOOLS THAT
COMPORT CURRENT LAW THAT'S
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. ERROR THAT OCCURRED
WHILE ROLE. OF DESIRE TO VOTE
ON VOTE AS OUT OF. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE THOSE. WELL. CLOSER
ALL TELEVISED FORTY EIGHT WAS
ELEVEN. THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEMS FORTY EIGHT THROUGH
FIFTY FOUR PASS RETAIN THIS IS
FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE AB
THIRTEEN OH FOUR BY MR SANTIAGO
FEBRUARY SOME WIGGLE THIRTEEN
OH FOUR BY SOME REMEMBER
SANTIAGO AN ACT RELATING TO
LAND USE MR SANTIAGO. BIGGEST
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB THIRTEEN
AFFORDABLE STRENGTHEN OUR FOR
HOUSE OBLIGATIONS TO HELP
DISMANTLE HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NIVAL. NAME IS SANTIAGO
SEEING NO. OF ON THE ITEM.
CARCLUB. WHAT IS THAT ABOUT ALL
MEMBERS VETERANS OUT OF A ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRED OF.
WELL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF ICE
VIDEO KNOWS. THE MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEMS. FIFTIES THROUGH
FIVE. PASSERO THIS IS FILE ITEM
SIXTIES. AB THREE SIXTY ONE MR
RIVAS CORPORATE. SOME PEOPLE
SIXTY ONE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS AN ACT RELATING TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT MISTER RIVAS
YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER YES- LEGISLATION
PROPOSES TO GRANT LOCAL
AGENCIES OR LEGISLATIVE BODIES
WITH THE FLEXIBILITY TO MEET
REMOTELY. WHEN THEIR EXPERIENCE
WITH THESE UNEXPECTED
EMERGENCIES THAT WOULD INHIBIT
IN PERSON GATHERINGS IN THIS
BILL ALSO SURE PUBLIC ACCESS
AND THAT THE PUBLIC BE ABLE TO
INSURE THAT THEY PARTICIPATE IN
THESE MEETINGS SHOULD THEY BE
NECESSARY VIA TELEPHONE OR
VIDEO CONFERENCE THIS BILL
BUILDS ON ON LESSONS THAT WE'VE
LEARNED- THAT THIS PAST YEAR
DURING THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC- AND WOULD CODIFY SOME
THE BEST PRACTICES THAT- WE'VE
SEEN BY LOCAL AGENCIES IN OF
VIEW WHEN IT COMES TO OUR
FUTURE STATES OF EMERGENCY THIS
LEGISLATION ONCE YOU'RE OPEN
AND TRANSPARENT GOVERNMENT.
WHEN WE NEED IT MOST IN FUTURE
TIMES OF SIGNIFICANT SOME
DESTRUCTION LIKE WE'VE
EXPERIENCED THIS PAST YEARS FOR
THESE REASONS RESPECT. THAT'S
RIVAL THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER. C.
NOTIFICATION OF A- CLICK CLUB.
SENATE VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
THAT A VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF.
THE DESERT OF. WELL CLOSER ALL
TELL HIS EIGHT KNOWS THREE
SEVEN PASS. FILE ITEM SIXTY SO
THREE SO PASS AND RETAIN FILE
SEVENTY ONE. IS AB FIVE OR SIX
BY MISS GONZALEZ CORKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE OH SIX BY
LORENA AND RELATING TO YOUTH
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS MS
GONZALEZ YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
AB FIVE OH SIX WOULD HELP
PREVENT CHILD ABUSE IN ADDRESS
A GAP FOR YOUTH ORGANIZATIONS
BY ADDING REGULAR VOLUNTEERS AS
MANDATED REPORTERS AND
REQUIRING THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION POLICIES
LIKE BACKGROUND CHECKS AND
TRAINING. FOR ALL EMPLOYEES
THIS BILL RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT COMMITTEE
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU RISK AND
SALAS SAYING. NO MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION. CABALLERO.
IT IS AT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS ARE
DESIRABLE ALL MEMBERS VOTE. IT
IS TO VOTE. WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE OF A I SIX NINE OH ZERO
THAT MEASURE FILE ITEM TWO
THROUGH TO PASS AND RETAIN.
FILE ITEM EIGHTY THREE IS AB
FIFTEEN NINETY THREE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL. FOR MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION- FOR THE CURRENT
YEAR ZERO THINK AFFECT ME
DEEPLY. MS GONZALEZ YOU MAY
AGAIN OPEN. THANK YOU AB
FIFTEEN NINETY THREE IS THE
CONSTITUTIONALLY REQUIRED BILL
TO APPROPRIATE FUNDS FOR PROOF
CLAIMS AGAINST THE STATE AB
FIFTEEN NINETY THREE WOULD
APPROPRIATE ONE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
GENERAL FUND TO THE VICTIM
COMPENSATION BOARD. PROCLAIMS
TWO INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE
WRONGLY CONVICTED OR IMPRISONED
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL
APPROPRIATES THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY NINE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED AND FORTY DOLLARS FOR
DEREK HERIS. HE WAS WRONGFULLY
CONVICTED OF ROBBERY AND
IMPRISONED WRONGFULLY FOR SEVEN
YEARS. THE BILL WOULD ALSO
APPROPRIATE NINE HUNDRED AND
680-008-0080 DOLLARS FOR JEREMY
POCKET HE WAS WRONGFULLY
CONVICTED FOR PER FOR MURDER.
AND HE SPENT NINETEEN. IN JAIL
FOR HE DID NOT COMMIT THESE TWO
CLAIMS HAVE ALREADY BEEN
APPROVED BUT WE NEED TO PASS
THIS BILL QUICKLY TO AND THE
HARDSHIP OF THESE INNOCENT
CLAIMANTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. I THINK IT WAS
CONTROLS MISTER GIBSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN NINETY
THREE I WOULD LIKE TO THINK
THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
DIEGO FOR BRINGING THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE. FOR MISTER
SPEAKER IF I COULD HAVE ORDERED
A HOUSE PLEASE. MEMBERS.THE
RETENTION MISTER GIBSON MR
GIBSON PROCEED PLEASE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I WOULD LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT ONE OF MY-
INDIVIDUAL CONSTITUENTS I WILL
RECEIVE THEIR FINANCIAL
COMPENSATION THAT MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN DIEGO JUST MAKE
MENTION- FOR PAROLE PLEA BEING
CONVICTED I REPRESENT THE WATTS
COMMUNITY WHERE I WAS BORN AND
RAISED. MR DEREK HARRIS. IS A
CONSTITUENT OF MINE. THIS IS A
MAN WHO WAS MINDING HIS OWN
BUSINESS. OUT CELEBRATING WITH
HIS GIRLFRIEND. HE WAS. HIS
FREEDOM WAS TAKEN AWAY. STOLEN
FROM HIM. HE WAS UNJUSTLY
ARRESTED IN CHARGE. THEN HE
WENT TO PAY. FOR CRIMES THEY
DIDN'T COMMIT FOR SEVEN YEARS
AND FOUR MONTHS BEHIND BARS.
THAT IS TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED AND ELEVEN DAYS. WHICH
IS ABOUT THREE MILLION MINUTES
WITHIN THOSE SEVEN YEARS THAT
HE SPENT BEHIND BARS UNJUSTLY
CONVICTED MISTER HARRIS CAN
NEVER GET BACK THOSE SEVEN
YEARS. DOES THIS SOUND FAMILIAR
COLLEAGUES. I SHOULD BE IT
SHOULD BE BECAUSE I HAPPEN TO
REPRESENTS COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN WRONGLY INDIVIDUALS
HAVE BEEN WRONGLY CONVICTED
JUST LIKE MISTER HARRIS PASS.
MEMBERS WE CANNOT GIVE BACK THE
SEVEN YEARS THAT HE SPENT FOUR
MONTHS IN PRISON. BUT THE
REMAINING YEARS THIS BILL
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN NINETY
THREE. MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A STRONG AYE VOTE. WE
CAN DO THIS SO WE CAN DO THIS
TOGETHER THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
STRONGLY ASK BUT I VOTE ON
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN NINETY
THREE. THANK YOU MUCH GIPSON I
SEE NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM. THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
MEMBERS. DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. IT IS OUT OF A.
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I. SIXTY NINE KNOWS
YOU'RE ON THE URGENCY HIGHS
SIXTY NINE NO ZERO ON THE BILL.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEMS
EIGHTY FOUR THREE EIGHTY NINE
PASS AND RETAIN. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE BACK IN THE FILE.
WE'RE BACK IN THE FILE TO TAKE
UP FILE ITEM SIX. THIS IS AB.
THREE THIRTY THREE. THE
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
THIRTY THREE BY FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KAMLAGER AN ACT
RELATING TO CRIMINAL GAINS
MISTER GRAY YOU MAY OPEN. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS. AB THREE THREE THREE
BY SENATOR KAMLAGER
SIGNIFICANTLY STRENGTHENS DUE
PROCESS RIGHTS BY REFORMING THE
USE OF GANG ENHANCEMENTS IN OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. MANY
OF YOU MAY BE SURPRISED TO SEE
ME JACKSON THIS BILL TODAY. IF
YOU WOULD CALL MY VOTING RECORD
SOFT ON CRIME. AND I
FUNDAMENTALLY DISAGREE WITH
MANY OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
BILLS THAT REACH THIS. FOR
HOWEVER ALSO FUNDAMENTALLY
AGREE THAT EVERY AMERICAN. USE
OF A CRIME HAS A RIGHT TO DUE
PROCESS. INCLUDING A FAIR TRIAL
BY AN IMPARTIAL JURY. THE
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL CAN SPEAK
FAR BETTER TO THE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACTS PEOPLE
OF COLOR HAVE EXPERIENCE
BECAUSE THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM'S FAILURE TO TREAT THEM
PARTIALLY. I'M SURE MANY OF YOU
HAVE HEARD HER PASSION
ARGUMENTS IN FAVOR OF THIS
BILL. AS I DID. FOR THOSE OF
YOU. WHO WERE ALREADY MOVED BY
HER WORDS I LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS BILL TODAY.
BUT LET ME SPEAK FOR A MOMENT
TO THOSE OF YOU STILL
CONTEMPLATING IS THIS THE RIGHT
SOLUTION TO THIS PROBLEM. MANY
OF US HAVE BEMOANED. THE WOKE
CULTURE OF TODAY WHICH FINDS
PEOPLE GUILTY IN THE EYE OF
PUBLIC OPINION BEFORE ANYTHING
BUT NATURALIZATION HAS BEEN
BROUGHT FORWARD. WE SEE PARITY
BETWEEN A LIBERAL COMPANY
FIRING A CONSERVATIVE EMPLOYEE
FOR EXPRESSING CONSERVATIVE
VIEWS AND THE CONSERVATIVE
COMPANY FIRING A LIBERAL PERSON
FOR EXPRESSING LIBERAL VIEWS.
IN A COUNTRY WHERE DIFFERENT
POINTS OF VIEWS RELIGIOUS
BELIEFS BACKGROUNDS ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE CELEBRATE. DUE
PROCESS IS THE GREAT EQUALIZER
TO ACT AS A BALANCE AGAINST THE
TYRANNY OF THE MAJORITY. REPEAT
OFFENDERS WORKING TO ADVANCE
THE CRIMINAL ENTERPRISE OF
STREET GANGS SHOULD FACE
STIFFER PENALTIES FOR THEIR
ACTIONS. HOWEVER THE CURRENT
GANG ENHANCEMENT SYSTEM CREATES
AN INHERENT BIAS. TO CONVICT A
PERSON FOR THE UNDERLYING CRIME
SIMPLY BECAUSE THE JURY KNOWS
THE PROSECUTION IS SEEKING A
GANG ENHANCEMENT. IF ASSEMBLED
CORRECTLY JURIES ARE NOT
INHERENTLY BIASED ENTITIES BUT
OUR LEGAL SYSTEM DOES A POOR
JOB OF KEEPING BIASES OUT OF
CRIMINAL PROCEEDINGS. WHEN WE
SEE GANG ENHANCEMENTS APPLIED
DISPROPORTIONATELY PEOPLE OF
COLOR WE HAVE TO ASK WHY. SO
THE QUESTION IS CASES WIRE 92%
OF PEOPLE WITH GANG
ENHANCEMENTS IN CALIFORNIA
PEOPLE OF COLOR. JUST IN CASE
WE NEED A REMINDER WHITE PEOPLE
CAN JOIN GANGS TO. AB THREE
THREE THREE REPRESENTS AN
HONEST ATEMPT. BY AN HONEST
MEMBER WHO DEEPLY AND
PERSONALLY CARES ABOUT THESE
ISSUES. IT MAKES CHANGES TO
PROCEEDINGS SO THAT
ENHANCEMENTS ARE ONLY BROUGHT
FORWARD AFTER DIFFERENT IS
ALREADY CONVICTED. OF THE
UNDERLYING CRIME. IT SIMPLY
REQUIRES. THAT JURIES AVOID PRE
SENTENCING SOMEONE SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY HAVE COMMITTED A
CRIME IN THE PAST. THAT IS WHAT
DUE PROCESS IS SUPPOSED TO
PROVIDE EVERY AMERICAN AND THAT
IS WHY I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE TODAY FOR AB. THREE
THREE THREE. I THINK IT'S GREAT
DOCTOR WEBER. IN THE REAR THE
CHAMBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THREE
THREE THREE. A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE TO RECTIFY UNJUST
APPLICATION A GANG ENHANCEMENT
ON COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
ACCORDING ACCORDING TO THE CDC
OUR DATA IN AUGUST OF TWENTY
NINETEEN. 90% OF INMATES WITH A
GANG ENHANCEMENT WERE BLACK OR
LATINO. TO BE CLEAR THESE AND.
IF APPROACH BY THE WAY HAS NO
EMPIRICAL EVIDENCE THAT IT
LEADS TO A DETERRENT FROM
JOINING A GANG. AND NO
EMPIRICAL EVIDENCE THAT IT
MAKES OUR COMMUNITY SAFER.
THESE GANG ENHANCEMENT
ENHANCEMENTS NOT ONLY EXTEND
THE LENGTH OF SENTENCES FOR
THESE INDIVIDUALS. BUT THESE
ENHANCEMENTS CONTINUE TO
PERPETUATE A CYCLE OF
DISRUPTION IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
WHICH LEAVE THE TO THE
CONTINUED CREATION OF UNHEALTHY
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES. AB
THREE THREE THREE INSTEAD FOCUS
IS ON THE REHABILITATION OF
THESE OFFENDERS. INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE ENTIRELY CAPABLE OF
BEING CONTRIBUTING MEMBERS TO
OUR SOCIETY IF GIVEN THE
APPROPRIATE TOOLS TO DO SO. WE
KNOW THAT A MORE HUMANE
APPROACH TO SENTENCING WILL
RESULT IN HEALTHIER INDIVIDUALS
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES
OVERALL. I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE ON AB THREE THREE
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU DR
WEBER MISTER COOPER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FROM YOUR DESK THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER- I RECOGNIZE
I WANTED THE COLORS FOR THEIR-
THEIR SPEECHES BUT EXISTING LAW
ALREADY ESTABLISHES THAT TO BE
CONVICTED OF A GANG ENHANCEMENT
YOU MUST BE PROVED BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT THE
COLLECTIVITY WAS COMMITTED TO
THE BENEFIT OR DIRECTOR OF A
STREET GANG. AB THREE THREE
THREE ADDS THE ALSO TO PROVEN
ESTABLISHED HIERARCHY THAT THE
ACT BENEFIT OTHER MEMBERS A
GANG OF THE PERPETRATOR THIS IS
NOT A SOPRANOS IS NOT SONS OF
ANARCHY. IT DOESN'T WORK THAT
WAY IT'S NOT ORGANIZED CRIMES
NOT THE MAFIA STREET GANGS EVER
STREET GANGS FOR OVER A DECADE
IS ATTACKING THE SERGEANT IS
NOT HEALTH STREET GANG FUNCTION
STREET GANGS OPERATE FOR
TERRITORIAL CONTROL AND POWER
THROUGH VIOLENCE AND
INTIMIDATION LOOK AT OUR
SHOOTING STATEWIDE ARE VIOLENCE.
IS UP BECAUSE THE STREET GANGS.
I'M REGIONAL ORGANIZE CRIME TO.
PER THE STREAK. IS TO PROMOTE
THEIR- OVER RIVAL GANGS BY
VIOLENCE AND OTHER METHODS. AB
THREE THREE ALSO PROHIBITS SOME
CRIMES WERE BEING INCLUDED
CRIMINAL STREET GANG SYNCING
ESTIMATES. IN A SPECIFIC
CONCERN OF ME IS. RESIDENTIAL
AND COMMERCIAL ROBBERY AND
FRAUD. THESE CRIMES THE STAPLE
OF THE CRIMINAL STREET GANG
THEY DON'T PAY THEIR LEADERS.
CRIMINAL STREET GANGS
ACTIVITIES ENTERPRISES FOR SOME
OF THE EXAMPLES HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. THE BLUSTERING WITH
IDENTIFY STREET GANG MEMBERS
AND SERVE THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
TWO SEARCH WARRANTS NINETY FOUR
CHARGED SIX INDIVIDUALS
ARRESTED. OVER A MILLION
DOLLARS RECOVERED DRUGS GUNS
ASSAULT RIFLES IN THE MAGAZINES
THIS IS ALL EDT FRAUD ONE
STAPLE OF IT. THEY ALSO
IDENTIFY PEOPLE DATES OF BIRTH
SOCIAL SECURITY'S AND THEY WERE
CHARGED WITH YOU BECAUSE WHEN
THE PUNISHMENTS FRAUD BEVERLY
HILLS FORTY FOUR PEOPLE
ARRESTED FOR EASY FRAUD
TOTALING TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION. DIRECTLY CONNECTS THE
STREET GANG MEMBERS HUNDRED
TWENTY I FALLING E. D. CARDS
WORTH OVER TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION RUN COVERED FIREARMS IN
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN CASH.
LA TWELVE STREET CRIMINAL
STREET GANG MEMBERS WERE
INDICTED IN A RESIDENTIAL
BURGLARY CONSPIRACY COVERING
FOR COUNTIES THE COUNTIES WERE
LA SYMPHONY WILL MATURE IN
ORANGE. INDICTMENTS LINK THE
DEFENDANTS TO THIRTY SEVEN
RESIDENTIAL BURGLARIES CONNECT
THIS CRIMINAL STREET GANGS
INTERNALLY COUNTY SEVERAL
STREET GANG MEMBERS ARE
ARRESTED FOR A SERIES OF
RESIDENTIAL BURGLARIES. RIFLES
HAND GUNS LARGE QUANTITY OF
AMMUNITION LARGE AMOUNT OF CASH
RECOVERED FROM THE BURGLARIES
SO RIGHT NOW THE LEGISLATURE
AUTHORIZED WERE PAYING FOR.
CAL- YES IN CC. TO BE THE-
BRING FUSION SENT. TO CALCULATE
ALL THESE. THE FOCUSING ON E.
D. THEFT FRAUD IN PRISONS AND
JAILS ARE CONNECTED TO
CONSTRUED GANGS. INCLUDING
HUNDRED SEVENTY SEPARATE
INVESTIGATIONS FIFTY SEVEN
TOWARDS OF AS OF AUGUST OF LAST
YEAR. SO A LOT GOES ON STREET
GANGS ARE DIFFERENT IT IS VERY
DIFFERENT AND BELIEVES OVER THE
PRISON SYSTEM SO YOU HAVE
ISSUES WITH THAT. BUT STREET
GANGS ARE FOR COLLECTIVITY AND
MOST THE MONEY TO GET. THE GOOD
THROUGH BURGLARIES LOOKING FOR
CASH LOOK FOR GUNS LOOK FOR
JEWELRY. TO SELL. AND THAT'S
THE THING WORKING STREET GANGS
IS NOT LIKE ANYTHING ELSE IT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE. IN THE
BIGGER ISSUE TO BE SET ON THIS
IS. I GUESS. WE DO SO MUCH FOR
ADULTS WOULD BE GOOD FOR KIDS
TO STOP THE SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE IT IS THERE IS REAL.
BUT WE REVITALIZED DOWNTOWN SAN
FRANCISCO LA SACRAMENTAL. WHAT
WE DON'T FAR WORSE COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE HORRIBLE SCHOOLS. NO
SUPERMARKETS NO BANKS NO
SUPPORTERS- ARTS PROGRAMS FOR
KIDS WE DON'T DO CRAP. THE SAME
MERRY'S AND SEKHEMRE THE BEEN
THAT WAY FOR YEARS THIRTY FORTY
FIFTY YEARS ARE STILL THE SAME
FOCUS ON THAT. BUT DON'T GIVE
GAINES A BREAK. THE A LOT OF
ISSUES WITH THAT AND A LOT OF
SUFFERING. AND THAT'S WITH THE
BIG ISSUE FOR WHAT A FIX IN
TARGET BUT LIKE I SAID THE
STAPLE OF THAT IS DOING. THE
ROBBERIES AND BURGLARIES IN
THIS CHANGES THAT AND THAT'S
WHERE THE BIG THING IS COMING
FROM SOMEONE NOT A POLITICIAN
THAT'S THE ONE THAT DID IT FOR
THIRTY YEARS. AND SPENT TN
YEARS IN THE GANG UNIT. AND IT
HAPPENS ON A DAILY BASIS SO WE
GOT TO FIX THIS BUT- LOSING A
LOSS NOT HELPING US AT ALL. SO
LET'S BUILD OUR KIDS A FIX THAT
FIX THAT BROKEN SYSTEM BUT I
DON'T REALLY LIVE IN THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. THOSE COMMUNITIES
AND PUBLIC MUSIC COLOR. THAT
HELL HAVE CRAP. BECAUSE NO LESS
TO INVEST IT IS MORE PORTABLE
ARENA SOMEWHERE. REVITALIZED
DOWNTOWN INVEST IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES THAT'S A REAL
ISSUE. AND UNTIL THAT CHANGES.
IS STATUS QUO BUT LIKE I SAID
THE GANG ISSUE IN THE V. D.
THING RIGHT NOW WE'RE ALL AWARE
OF IT WE'VE TALKED ABOUT ABOUT
NAUSEAM. THAT'S THE BIG ISSUE
DEAL WITH THAT. RIGHT NOW
AMONGST OTHER THINGS BUT- EXIT
WELL WELL WELL WELL INTENDED IT
DEFINITELY HITS THE MARK MAX
I'M SORRY IT MISSES THE MARK.
THERE IS COVERAGE PARA QUE HAN
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THREE THREE THREE. YOU KNOW I
COULDN'T AGREE MORE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO THAT
WE HAVE SO MUCH WORK TO DO ON
BUILDING UP COMMUNITIES OF
COLOUR. PROVIDING THEM WITH THE
EDUCATION THEY DESERVE WITH THE
RESOURCES THEY DESERVE SO THAT
CHILDREN CAN GROW UP. TO
SUCCEED AND THRIVE. I DON'T
KNOW THAT ANYONE ON THIS BOARD
DISAGREES WITH THAT PROMISE BUT
THE QUESTION IS BEFORE US TODAY
AS MR GREY SO APTLY PUT IT. IS
WHAT LEVEL OF DUE PROCESS IS
REQUIRED WHEN WE TACK ON THESE
INCREDIBLE ENHANCEMENTS. THE
ROBBERIES THAT OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM SACRAMENTO SPOKE ABOUT.
EVERY SINGLE PERSON WHO IS
CONVICTED OF THOSE ROBBERIES
WILL SERVE THE TIME FOR THE
UNDERLYING CRIME. THIS DOES NOT
CHANGE THAT WE SET THOSE. THOSE
FENCES. AND THEIR SENTENCES ARE
SERVED. AND THEN ON TOP OF THAT
AS MANY OF YOU HAVE SEEN IF YOU
LOOK AT THE DATA. ON THIS BILL
AND THE CHANGES THAT WILL AND
IT WILL HAPPEN IF WE PUT IT
INTO PLACE. IS THAT PEOPLE OF
COLOR ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
GIVEN THESE ENHANCEMENTS. AND
ONCE THESE ENHANCEMENTS OR
TALKED ON. WE IS A STATE DO NOT
DEMAND DUE PROCESS. WE ARE
INCARCERATING PEOPLE OF COLOR
FOR LONGER PERIODS OF TIME.
WITHOUT THE DUE PROCESS THAT
THOSE INDIVIDUALS DESERVE. THAT
IS THE QUESTION BEFORE YOU
TODAY COLLEAGUES. DO THESE
INDIVIDUALS DESERVE DUE
PROCESS. WHEN THEY ARE HAVING
THESE SENTENCES PLACED ON TO
THEM. AND I HOPE THAT EACH AND
EVERYONE OF YOU WILL ANSWER
THAT IN THE AFFIRMATIVE.
BECAUSE THAT IS THE LEAST IT
SHOULD BE EXPECTED IN A
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN BRING A LITTLE
BIT MORE JUSTICE TO THAT SYSTEM
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU IS
BURKE A HEY MISTER MURATSUCHI.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I RISE IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL. YOU KNOW. I THINK
WE ALL RECOGNIZE THAT. WE'VE
BEEN FOCUSING A LOT MORE ON THE
ROOT CAUSES OF CRIME. AND
THAT'S RIGHTFULLY SO. THAT'S
WHY WE ENVISIONED IT THE
DIFFICULT WORK OF GETTING MORE
INVESTMENTS IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR SO THAT WE ADDRESS THE
ROOT CAUSES OF CRIME. BUT I WAS
STRUCK BY THE FACT THAT THE
VICTIMS. ALL OF CRIMINAL GANG
ACTIVITIES. THERE ARE PRIMARILY
COMING FROM LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. JUST A
FEW WEEKS AGO I WENT TO OUR
EVENT IN MY DISTRICT SPONSORED
BY A GROUP. JUSTICE. FOR THE
PARENTS IF IT JUSTICE FOR
FAMILIES WITH WITH MURDER
CHILDREN. LED BY A GROUP THAT
TO MISTER GIBSON AND I KNOW.
WOMAN NAMED LOW WANDA HAWKINS.
AND I WAS STRUCK BY HOW THE
VICTIMS THE FAMILIES OF THE
VICTIMS THERE WERE
OVERWHELMINGLY BLACK AND BROWN
PEOPLE. AND SO. YOU KNOW I MEAN
I KNOW THAT THERE IS A PROBLEM
WITH MASS INCARCERATION. WITH
TOO MUCH OF THAT COMING AT THE
EXPENSE OF BLACK AND BROWN-COMMUNITIES BUT JUST SIMPLY
**** NILLY. REDUCING. THE
PENALTIES THE CRIMINAL
PENALTIES. TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE OF MASS INCARCERATION IS
NOT THE RIGHT WAY TO GO. THOSE
PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN THE LONG
CONTINUES A COLOR DESERVE JUST
AS MUCH PROTECTIONS AS ANYONE
ELSE. THAT IS WHY I'M OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL. I THINK IT WAS
MURATSUCHI MISTER KALRA. YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AND- YOU KNOW EIGHTY
THREE THIRTY THREE THE STEP
FORWARD OUT OF. BUT ADDRESS THE
PROPER USE OF GETTING HAS RISEN
A COUPLE JUSTICE SYSTEM BECAUSE
CURRENTLY GETTING OUT HOUSES
ARE OFTEN USED FOR LESLIE
WILLIAMS EARLY AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY AGAINST
PEOPLE OF COLOR THE RESULT IN
SYSTEMIC FINALIZATION OF
CULTURES AND COMMUNITIES
HOWEVER THIS CHANGE IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT'S BEING TAKEN
LIGHTLY. THAT ACTUALLY WAS A
POLICY RECOMMENDATION PROVIDED
IN THE CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE ON
THE REVISION OF THE PENAL CODE
THEY SPEND A LOT OF TIME AND
ENERGY WITH EXPERTS SEEING WHAT
ARE THE WHAT ARE THE COMPONENTS
ARE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
BUT OF NOT ONLY LEAD TO MASS
INCARCERATION BUT
DISPROPORTIONATE INCARCERATION.
SO THIS BILL DOES NOT SEEK TO
MAKE THE APPLICATION AGAIN
HASN'T IMPOSSIBLE RATHER
REQUIRES A SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE
PROVIDED IN ORDER TO PROVE THAT
THE UNDERLYING OFFENSE WAS
ACTUALLY. COMMITTED ON BEHALF
OF THE GAME. SO THIS IS NOT
LOSE LAWS IS ACTUALLY
INCREASING THE DUE PROCESS
PROTECTIONS IN COURT. SO DON'T
BELIEVE THE FEAR MONGERING WHEN
IT COMES TO- NOW BURGLARS ARE
INCLUDED IN FACT THE CDA THE
DISK ATTORNEYS WHO OPPOSED THE
BILL AS YOU CAN IMAGINE IN
GENERAL THEY ACTUALLY SUPPORT
REMOVING BURGLARY LOOTING
VANDALISM AND SUCH. AS A
SPECIFIC CRIMES THAT CAN BY
THEMSELVES CREATE THE EVIDENCE
NECESSARY TO SHOW THAT ONE IS A
MEMBER OF A CRIMINAL STREET
GANG YOU CAN STILL HAVE A GANG
ENHANCEMENT ADDED. ONTO AN EDG.
OF IT WILL BE A CRIME REGARDING
U. D. D. OR BURGLARY OR
VANDALISM BUT THOSE SURPRISED
BY THEMSELVES CAN'T SHOW THAT
YOU'RE PART OF A SHOULD YOU
HAVE TO SHOW THE ELEMENTS WITH
THE ADOPTION REQUIRE THE
REQUIRED TO SHOW YOU'RE PART OF
A THREE GAME AND THEN I THAT
ENHANCEMENT IF THOSE TYPE OF
THAT TYPE OF CONDUCT IS DONE.
IN THE FURTHERANCE OF THE
STREET GANG IT'S COMMON SENSE
IT MAKES SENSE THAT I WAS DUE
PROCESS. THAT DOESN'T ALLOW.
THE REAL VAGUENESS ACROSS OCCUR.
OR LONG FOR. YOU JUST SAY
WITHOUT FIRST AS A MEMBER OF A
GANG AND WE JUST CHARGED WITH
THIS CRIME SO NOW THAT AGAIN
HAS BEEN THAT ADDS A DUE
PROCESS NOBODY IS OFF THE HOOK
EVERYONE HELD ACCOUNTABLE AND
CRIMES ARE COMMITTED. PART OF
AND IN FURTHERANCE OF A
CRIMINAL STREET GANG. DOES
DRINKING HAS IS WILL CONTINUE.
TO BE APPLIED. SO PLEASE DON'T
LISTEN TO THIS CONTINUAL FEAR
MONGERING WHENEVER WE'RE TRYING
TO DO SOMETHING THAT ACTUALLY
IS COMMONSENSE. ORIENTED THAT
ACTUALLY HAS US GIVING DUE
PROCESS TO EVERYONE INVOLVED
INCLUDING THE ACCUSED AND THE
VICTIMS. THAT'S WHAT. AB THREE
THREE THREE DOES THAT ALLOWS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO FIX
SOMETHING IN FACT. WHEN GAME
HAS REFERS IN ORDERS OF THAT
WAS THE INTENTION WHAT HAPPENED
WAS OVER THE YEARS AS TOUGH ON
CRIME MASS INCARCERATION.
PIPELINE WAS CREATED THEY MADE
IT MORE AND MORE LOSING
DEFINITION AND MORE A MORE
STRINGENT IN PUNISHMENT. WORDS
TO. RESET AND CORRECT THE
MISTAKES HAVE BEEN MADE WELL
MAKING SURE THAT WE CAN STILL
ALL ALL THE TOOLS NECESSARY. TO
GO AFTER CRIMINAL STREET GANGS
IN OUR COMMUNITY BUT DO IN A
WAY THAT ACTUALLY ATTACKS THE
PROBLEM AND DOESN'T CAST A WIDE
NET. THAT IS RIGHT NOW AND
STIRRING FAR TOO MANY. OF OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER KALRA MR LOW FROM
YOUR DESK YOUR RECORDS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BETTER MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES A
COLLEGE WHEN I FIRST. THIS WAS
MADE AWARE OF THIS BILL I HAD
SIGNIFICANT HESITATION. IN FACT
MY GUT TOLD ME THAT PERHAPS I
COULD NOT GET THERE ESPECIALLY
WITH RESPECT TO THE CURRENT
CLIMATE ON THE- ASIAN FOR
SILENT OR HATE. BUT I'LL TELL
YOU AS WE I'VE HAD OPPORTUNITY
TO READ THE LEGISLATION AND SO
HEARING FROM SOME BAD GET
SPECIFIC IN THE DISTRICT AND
STATEWIDE. IT'S QUITE
COMPELLING THIS IS A CIRCLE
SURGICAL APPROACH AND
ADDRESSING THE SYSTEMIC RACISM
IN OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
I KNOW THAT WE CAN DO BETTER
WITHOUT. JEOPARDIZING THE
STOPPING ASIAN PROVIDER HATE
AND WITH RESPECT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU MITCHELL-
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM. MISTER
GRAY YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU FOR THE
DIALOGUE AND- CONVERSATION ON
THE BILL- AS YOU KNOW MEMBERS I
HAVE GREAT RESPECT FOR MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO. AND
HIS BACKGROUND IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT. WE AGREE ON 99% OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT ISSUES AND I
HAVE A STRONG PRO LAW
ENFORCEMENT RECORD THIS IS A
FAIR BILL THIS IS A FAIR
AUTHOR- IT'S NOT GONNA SOLVE
EVERY PROBLEM IN THIS SPACE
THERE'S MORE WORK TO BE DONE-
THERE'S MORE WORK TO BE DONE ON
THIS BILL I THINK WE'RE GOING
TO NEED TO MASSAGE SOME OF THE
LANGUAGE IN HERE- AS WE MOVE
THIS BILL THROUGH THE PROCESS.
WHEN I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY THE
UNDERLYING ISSUE IS A RIGHTEOUS
ONE- AND DESERVES THE SUPPORT
OF THIS BODY RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU IS GREAT WITH
THAT CLUB CLUB THE ROLE.
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
MISTER GREG WITH THE CALL
MISTER GRAY MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
MISTER GRACE ADDITIONAL ITEM
HERE THIS IS FILE ITEM. TWENTY
FIVE AB. TWO THIRTY SEVEN. ONCE
AGAIN OUT OF TWENTY FIVE AB TWO
THIRTY SEVEN CORPORATION
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO THIRTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY AND
OTHERS AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT MR GRAY YOU
MAKE AN OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS. AB TWO THIRTY
SEVEN PROHIBITS PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES FROM TERMINATING THE
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE OF
EMPLOYEES AND THEIR DEPENDENTS
DURING A WORK STOPPAGE OR
STRIKE. THERE IS NO EXCUSE TO
LEVERAGE A FAMILY'S ABILITY TO
ACCESS MEDICAL CARE AS A
MECHANISM TO BREAK A STRIKE.
STATE LAW SHOULD BE CLEAR THAT
EVEN THE THREAT OF SUCH A
TACTIC IS IN AND OF ITSELF AN
UNFAIR LABOR PRACTICE AND
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC EMPLOYERS
SHOULD NEVER ENGAGE IN SUCH
ACTIVITY. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE ON AB TWO THIRTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU MISS GRAY. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
CARCLUB RURAL. YOU DESERVE IT
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF OUR DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THANK WELL THOSE ARE ALL
TIED UP ICE FIFTY EIGHT KNOWS
EIGHT THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A LOT OF MY
CALL. ONE ITEM- REMAINS ON CALL
A COUPLE OF QUICK ANNOUNCEMENTS
MEMBERS AC OUR COLLEAGUE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAD MAYES IN
THE REAR CHAMBER LET'S ALL
CONGRATULATE CHAD HE WAS
MARRIED OVER THE WEEKEND
GRADUATION. I M. MEMBER CENTER
STAND DR ARAMBULA IS
CELEBRATING A BIRTHDAY TODAY
HAPPY BIRTHDAY DR ARAMBULA.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL. ON THE REMAINING ITEM
THIS IS A MISTER GRAY- AUTHOR
KAMLAGER AB THREE THREE THREE
THE CLERK WILL POST. ALL
MEMBERS WHO WISH TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED WHICH TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL. CLOSER ROLE TALLY
THE VOTE AS THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS
TWENTY FOUR THAT MEASURE FAILS
MISTER GREG PERSINGER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
RECONSIDERATION MISTER GRAY AND
NOTICES RECONSIDERATION.
ANNOUNCEMENTS SESSION SCHEDULE
IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY MAY
EIGHTEENTH CHECK IN SESSION.
WEDNESDAY MAY NINETEENTH CHECK
IN SESSION THURSDAY MAY TWENTY
FOUR SESSION. IS AT NINE AM ALL
OF THE ITEMS REMAINING WILL BE
PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTION SHALL
BE CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING
A FOR THE BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MS RAMOS MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE. STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY MAY
TWENTIETH AT NINE AM IN THE
QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED.
VALIDATORS AB THIRTEEN OH FOUR
NOTED NOT VOTING. CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VALIDATORS
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN OH FOUR
NO TO NOT VOTING.